We need a numerical procedure,
which is easy in one direction
and hard in the other.
This brings us to modular
arithmetic, also known
as clock arithmetic.
For example, to
find 46 mod 12, we
could take a rope
of length 46 units
and wrap it around a
clock of 12 units, which
is called the modulus, and where
the rope ends is the solution.
So we say 46 mod 12
is congruent to 10.
Easy.
Now, to make this work, we use
a prime modulus, such as 17.
Then we find a
primitive root of 17.
In this case, 3, which has this
important property that, when
raised to different
exponents, the solution
distributes uniformly
around the clock.
3 is known as the generator.
If we raise 3 to any
exponent x, then the solution
is equally likely to be any
integer between 0 and 17.
Now, the reverse
procedure is hard.
Say, given 12, find the exponent
3 needs to be raised to.
This is called the
discrete logarithm problem.
And now we have our one way
function, easy to perform,
but hard to reverse.
Given 12, we would have to
resort to trial and error
to find matching exponents.
How hard is this?
Well, with small
numbers it's easy,
but if we use a prime modulus,
which is hundreds of digits
long, it becomes
impractical to solve.
Even if you had access to all
computational power on earth,
it could take thousands
of years to run
through all possibilities.
So the strength of
a one way function
is based on the time
needed to reverse it.